il faut imaginer la soft république
comme une espèce de laboratoire géant
voilà le siège de la software république
le bâtiment odyssée construit à côté du
technocentre renault de guyancourt
il devrait accueillir à partir du mois
de septembre 2021
les premières équipes composées de
collaborateurs venant des cinq grands
groupes fondateurs
atos dassault systèmes
stmicroelectronics thales et renault là
on assurément des l'horizontale donc au
des grandes entreprises se remettre
ensemble parce que les enjeux sur
lesquels on travaille la digitalisation
la transition énergétique
c'est des thèmes qui coupent
horizontalement le secteur dans le cadre
de la software et publique ses cinq
grands fleurons français vont apporter
leurs compétences
une mutualisation des expertises dans la
mobilité des composants électroniques
l'intelligence artificielle le big data
et la cyber sécurité
objectif développer des solutions
numériques et écologique pour la
mobilité de demain
je pense qu'à travers software
république on peut nous 5 et beaucoup
d'autres montrer qu'on a tout ce qu'il
faut en europe pour construire cette
mobilité intelligente il va falloir que
on accueille on attire beaucoup d'autres
membres des grands des moyens des petits
des startups du monde académique pour
vraiment faire vivre ce projet horizon
tellement on est en train de changer de
paradigme en fait on en train de passer
d'une automobile connectés certes mais à
des systèmes hyperconnecté les
smartphones sur sur seront en fait c'est
un des apports qu'on se propose de de
mettre sur la table c'est de cette
capacité à cyber sécuriser des systèmes
pour lequel sans prendre l'avis des gens
peuvent être en jeu d'autres grands
groupes centres de recherche de type1
start up pourrait rejoindre la software
république
l'objectif à terme est de proposer des
offres globales de services autour de la
mobilité aux collectivités aux
industriels et aux particuliers